so black party is just around the corner
and I know that a lot of you guys are
planning to build a brand new PC so
here's the ultimate value PC build for
dis Black Friday first of all I want to
say it this is not the cheapest PC that
you can build as Black Friday and I did
not just go in at cheapest parts that
were available instead I added that
parts that had the highest discount so
you would get the best value so this
isn't necessarily the cheapest build but
it's very high value so starting off
with the CPU if you guys didn't already
watch my video about wide 1700 X is the
CPU to buy this Black Friday and make
sure to check that out but long story
short it has a sixty two point five
percent discount and it is a solid eight
core 16 third CPU and it is only 150
dollars are now as a base clock of three
point four gears and a boost clock of
3.8 Hertz and it is absolutely
unbeatable value
next up ask you the CPU cooler you could
definitely get a really nice air cooler
which is cheaper to this but I thought
the coarser 860 would be nice addition
especially due to a great discount
that's going to be coming up soon from
seven dollars to fifty dollars which is
about 30% it is a really nice all-in-one
liquid cooler that just came off earlier
this year and has a 120 millimeter rad I
think it's a good value for $50 it will
definitely provide you with really good
cooling you may even be able to
overclock off your 4 gigahertz ask for
the motherboard I want to include a full
sized ATX motherboard so that you have
four or Ram slots and two PCI Express
Lanes overall what's an ATX motherboard
you just have a lot more upgrade ability
in the future so I really want to go
with an ATX motherboard and ask for the
combination between be 350 and X 370 I
really don't think there's any point
with going with X 370 so as far as the
motherboard goes I put in the MSI PC
mate be 350 gaming motherboard for $60
if you guys want some red actions to go
along with your motherboard then you can
spend an extra five dollars and get the
gaming + motherboard from MSI as far as
harddrive goes there really aren't very
many enticing deals going on right now
all the good deals are for the high
storage devices like a terabyte or ten
terabyte so I just printed a Western
Digital 2 terabyte hard drive for $50
but on the day of Black Friday or
Thanksgiving you may be able to find
this to
by hardware for cheaper or get more
storage for the same price to make sure
keep an eye out for that so I found this
Western Digital SSD for 500 gigabytes
and it's actually good this guy 30% we
should usually cost hundred dollars and
get it for $7.00 right now if you want
something even nicer
you can spend 10 more dollars and get
the Samsung 850 Evo for $80 this Black
Friday that's for the case I chose the
thermal take view 31 case because a very
steep discount and looks really nice it
has a really nice full side view and
glass on the front as well
it normally calls from $100 but soon you
can actually pick it up for half that at
$50 finally the GPU in my opinion the
arcs 5 65 70 and 580 and a 10 15 1060
are all really great 1080p gaming cards
at this point if you're looking into the
future I really think you should at
least get a g6 1070 with any of those
other cards a couple of years you will
have turn on the graphics settings if I
maintain 60 frames per second but with
the gtx 1070 are anything higher will
last you many many years for the future
so really i think that you guys should
consider a 1070 or higher and the gtx
1080i is way overpriced so that's out of
the picture and it so is our TX and Vega
so it really comes down to gtx 1070 1070
TI or 1080 right now the cheapest 1070 i
and 1070 are just separated by $10 so
the clear choice right here is the 1070
TI I really recommend you guys go with
the 1070 I as long as the practicality
under 1070 and 1070 TI it's $30 or less
the price difference be the cheapest
1070 Ti and 1080 is $100 and I really
don't think the 1080 is worth a hundred
or more than 1070 TI so in my opinion
don't consider 1080 unless the price
type is virgin intense MBTI and 1080 is
$50 or less so based on all of that the
perfect middle ground at least as of
right now if the gtx 1070 TI and that
comes in at $350 in the end this will
give you a power of Bolton 8-bit gaming
PC or a solid 1440p gaming machine and
it cost less than $1000 at $920 if you
had a Windows 10 on top of that it comes
out to 1005 dollars to write about $1000
without these deals this PC would cost
in the high 1100 through saving a solid
books so what do you guys think about my
choices make sure to comment down below
what you guys would change and why you
would change it and what do you guys
think about my gpus choice also the guys
likes to be on the mixer drop the like
and consider subscribing if you like see
more videos just like this one tomorrow
I'm going to be posting video about the
best Black Friday deals as far as
peripherals go like gaming headsets
keyboards Mouse's and all that type of
stuff so make sure to stay tuned for
that but until then I'm Hari I'll see
you guys next one
[Music]
you